in the last video i touched on the core
weakness of fractional reserve banking
and that's the idea
of the bank run
where if you have a bunch of banks and
they've all lend out 90 of their
reserves so let's say that here's all my
bank bank one
bank two
bank three and you could have a ton of
banks i mean you could imagine you go
all the way to bank a hundred the
problem with a bank run is if just even
one bank all of a sudden isn't able to
give its depositors its money so it is
illiquid
illiquid and will reserve judgment as to
whether it is truly insolvent but it
really just doesn't have the money to
give its depositors then all the
depositors of all of the other banks get
scared and run over to the banks and ask
for their money back and by definition
in a fractional reserve banking system
these guys only have 10 percent of their
10 percent of their re of their deposits
as reserves 10 reserves
so if more than 10 percent of the people
ask for their money they're all going to
be a liquid
you're all going to be illiquid
and then you're going to have just an
all-out panic you're going to have an
all-out panic of the financial system
people as soon as any of these guys
loans come due so let me draw one of
their balance sheets let's assume that
they were actually good investors which
is a big assumption but let's just say
let's say that their balance sheets look
like this
here's all of the deposits that they owe
to people to me and you
that's their liabilities they have 10
of their assets as actual currency
reserves
looks like that that's the reserves
right there and then the rest is loans
out
loans out to businesses and whatever
else
their loans out
to random businesses so these are
loans and that's an asset because
businesses owe them something then
what's going to happen as soon as
they're a panic everyone wants their
money out the reserves are depleted very
quickly
so you have the reserves see if i can
you have the reserves get depleted very
quickly and then these guys sit there
waiting for their money essentially it
shuts down the bank as soon as these
loans
as soon as these loans mature maybe this
guy owed his money in a year then
they're gonna say just give me the money
back i'm not gonna renew the loan even
though you have a good business and so
everyone's gonna want their money back
and the whole financial system is going
to break down and credit is going to
freeze panic
and then you're going to have a freezing
of credit
freezing of credit
and this is a huge problem remember this
could be just caused by one bad actor
who couldn't manage their liquidity
properly even worse it could be managed
it could be caused just by one panicky
withdrawal there doesn't even have to be
a bad actor it could just be some fear
that enters the system and even for
completely legitimate bank and i'll use
legitimate quotations because we're
assuming
legitimate
because some would debate whether
fractional reserve banking is legitimate
but even if this is a completely
up and up bank if for whatever reason
more than 10 percent of their deposits
get scared then all of a sudden they'll
be illiquid and you'll be in this
all-out panic condition now i talked in
the last video some of the things that
have been engineered to fix this problem
so these are the fixes
the first one is to have a banker of
lasters or a lender of last resort
lender of last
resort
and that's our central bank or the
federal reserve bank
the federal
reserve bank
and they'll never run out of reserves
because these
these reserves can be lent borrowed from
them
and all these are are ious ious
from
the federal reserve
so what the federal reserve does and
i've talked about this in the past is
let's say that their balance sheet
currently looks like this let's say that
this is
their current liabilities these are
their current assets and their current
liabilities are essentially going to be
ious these are going to be these reserve
notes but let's say someone else comes
and says hey federal reserve lend me
some money lend me some money so what
they're going to do
is that they're going to
print some so these are federal reserve
notes
federal reserve notes that are like that
and then they're going to just create an
offsetting liability and they have no
they have no reserve limits let me make
it a new color just to ease the monotony
so they'll have this corresponding notes
outstanding liability and then they're
going to give those notes to you
they're going to give those notes to the
bank that's in a desperate situation if
it couldn't lend it borrow from any
other bank
and so the federal reserve balance sheet
will now look like this this is what it
would look like before
it has these new notes outstanding
notes outstanding and now this will say
instead of federal reserve notes and
it's in its in its vaults it'll now have
this little thing on its books called
loan to
to the bank loan to this guy right here
which is an asset because he owes him
something and the federal there's no
limit to which the federal reserve could
do this obviously there might be some
kind of implicit limits if they keep
doing this arbitrarily people might not
accept these federal reserve notes as
actually carrying value so that's
probably the main limiting concern and
i'll probably talk more in future videos
on other things that are kind of keeping
the federal reserve from just doing this
willy-nilly but the general idea is that
they never run out so this is one idea
lender of last resort but not even the
federal reserve wants to keep doing this
because what if this guy what if this
guy is essentially insolvent if these
loans are actually going bad
if these loans are actually getting
stinky right here they're starting to
smell
then there's no reason that even the
central bank should actually be lending
to this guy you shouldn't be lending to
this guy so let's say the federal
reserve looks at this guy's books and
say you know what these loans are really
worthless i'm not going to lend more
money to you what i'm going to do is
take you into receivership and i haven't
even talked about what that is that's
the second fix
the second fix is to have this notion
this notion of insurance
of federal
of deposit insurance
deposit
insurance
so if a bank is just has a liquidity
problem it's a good bank and i'll put
good in in quotation marks it's a good
bank
good bank
it just ran out of reserves and no other
bank is willing to lend to it which
might you might debate whether it's even
a good bank if the other banks aren't
willing to lend to it then it can go to
the it can go to the discount window at
the federal reserve and borrow some
reserve notes now in the situation where
even that's not good enough and the bank
is essentially out of business it had
been paying the fdic a little bit of
money the federal
deposit
insurance corporation
insurance
corporation
a little bit of money i mean probably a
lot of money by an individual's point of
view but a little bit of money from a
bank's point of view and
it's it's a fraction of a percent a
little bit of money every year so that
it could tell us depositors look even in
the situation that our bank goes bust
the federal reserve is going to pay you
directly if these are fdic bank accounts
the federal reserve will make you whole
completely regardless of what happens to
the banks
now this
this to me is a big fix i mean i'll tell
you right now all of my savings right
now are in federal deposit insured fdic
insured
fdic insured bank accounts now this
might sound great to the depositor but
what's the side effect on the banking
system well let me draw all of my banks
again
so i have bank one i have bank two i
have bank three i have bank four now
they are all fdic insured
they are all fdic insured they pay some
small fraction of a percentage every
year
so that they can tell their depositors
look if we ever go bust if we ever blow
up for whatever reason your deposits are
a hundred percent safe
are 100 safe
now what's going to happen this will
solve the bank run problem right let's
say for whatever reason this guy runs
out of reserves or he goes bankrupt
let's say that this guy goes bankrupt
and the old situation before the
insurance everyone else is going to get
scared and you're going to have a bank
run and they're going to ask for their
money and there's just not going to be
enough reserves because they only keep a
fraction of the reserves that's what
fractional reserve banking is but now
everyone's going to feel comfortable
like you know what everything is backed
by the federal reserve which can print
as many notes as it wants
so i'm just going to sit pretty so this
does solve the bank run problem
solve
the bank
run problem and so you might say hey you
know this doesn't make it an unstable
equilibrium anymore which is kind of
true but what does this do
all of these guys are now fdic insured
i'm equally willing to give my money to
eat any of these guys so i'm essentially
going to give my money to the guy who
gives me the highest interest
give
deposit
to the highest interest
highest interest and i've actually done
that with my personal accounts i've gone
and i've seen which bank provides the
highest interest and i've ignored how
they're investing their money i mean
otherwise i'd be pretty suspicious about
a bank offering more interest because
they're probably doing something risky
but now i don't care because i know it's
fdic insured and even if that bank blows
up i'm going to get all my money back so
i might as well give my deposit to the
bank with the highest interest
now based on what you saw in that last
video which is the bank that's going to
be giving the highest interest what's
going to be the bank that's taking on
the most risk
that is taking on
the most
risk
so once again when you give this
relatively cheap insurance
cheap insurance
to all of these banks and all of these
banks can attract money much easier by
paying this insurance if they didn't
have this insurance they would have to
pay much more let's say this insurance
is you know let's say it's 0.1 percent
per year
if they didn't have this insurance they
would have to pay much more than point
one percent per year to the depositor in
interest to make up for the risk that
they're taking on that they're not being
backed by the government so it's a
really good deal for the depositor they
pay 0.1 let's put it this way when you
give a deposit to a bank you're lending
money to the bank so your your checking
deposit rate so let me write this down
your
checking
deposit
interest rate
is the same thing as the bank's
borrowing costs right when i go to some
bank and they're paying me two percent a
year that's the bank's borrowing cost
banks
borrowing cost
they're the same thing now if the bank
didn't have fdic insurance it wouldn't
have to pay 0.1 percent a year but it
would have to give me more interest it
would have to pay me three or four
percent i probably more because i'd say
this is a risky bank or it's more risky
any bank will be more risky than the
than someone who can print out the notes
so it would have to pay more but now it
can just pay 0.1 percent a year
now it can just pay 0.1 percent a year
pay 0.1 percent or whatever the federal
deposit insurance corporation pays it
but it's going to lower
to fdic it pays that to the fdic but the
main side effect like of this is it's
going to lower what it has to pay to
depositors because the pods are going to
say oh this is a lot safer than what i
thought so it's going to lower
borrowing costs
borrowing
costs
by much more
by much more than
point one percent so it's a really good
deal for the banks and so it's an
especially good deal for the for the
ultra risky banks who might have to pay
a little bit more but because they can
now do super duper risky things you say
hey but you know this is insurance the
federal deposit insurance corporation
isn't stupid it should just charge more
for riskier banks but my i guess the the
rebuttal to that is that's easier said
than done because when times are good
when times are good
like in the 20s or in the or during the
housing bubble times are good
you get hidden risk risk gets hidden so
you don't risk gets hidden so you don't
know who's taking on the risk it's
usually the person who's getting the
highest returns but if they're if they
if they're always good for it you don't
see it and that person just looks like a
genius
that person just looks like a genius
when times are good and then when times
are bad
that guy blows up but guess what he's
not on the line for it it's the federal
deposit insurance corporation who all
along was probably under charging for
that insurance
i want to make one last point about this
you know it's called insurance it's a
federal deposit insurance corporation
insurance corporation
and i want to point out the difference
between financial insurance and you
could watch my video on credit default
swaps which is another form of financial
insurance between financial insurance
and what we normally associate with
insurance
if i have car insurance let's say i'm a
car insurance
person and i agree
you know let's say that they are driver
one let's say i have a bunch of drivers
so driver one
driver two
driver 3
driver 4 and i know that in any given
year they each have a 10 percent chance
10 percent chance
of an accident that's a lot higher than
reality but will make the numbers easy
and if there is an accident it will cost
me
ten thousand dollars
ten thousand
dollars
so i could go to driver one say look
there's a ten percent chance you're
going to have an accident it would cost
ten thousand dollars if you do so i'm
going to charge you the fair price would
be a thousand i'll charge you 1100 so
i'll charge
1100 just so i can make a little bit of
a profit right what you would charge is
a thousand if you wanted to break even
but i'll charge 1100 and i might do this
more than just four drivers i might do
with 4 000 drivers so on average in any
given year in any given year let's say i
have
let's say i have
one let's say i have a 1 million drivers
1 million
drivers in any given year how much am i
going to bring in i'm going to bring in
a million times eleven hundred dollars
which is i'm gonna get 1.1 billion
in input or in revenue
from people paying their premiums and
how much am i going to have to pay out
what's going to be my payout
my payout
well roughly 10 percent if you believe
these statistics are going to have an
accident
so that means that 100 000 are going to
have an accident each of those 100 000
accidents are gonna cost me ten thousand
dollars ten thousand times a hundred
thousand i'm gonna have to pay out one
billion
for the accidents so i will net every
year my statistics if my actuaries did
their job i will net 100 million every
year
and this works out pretty good assuming
these statistics are right and people
are willing to pay the premium because
if you have enough drivers like a
million drivers the statistics really
hold in any given year the chance of 20
of the drivers having an accident is
very very very almost infinitesimally
small it's almost zero and one driver
having an accident doesn't make it more
or less likely that another driver will
have an accident when you're talking
about on the order of a million drivers
and that's true of health insurance and
everything else it's just purely
probabilistic and if you have enough
people insured the statistics can
actually hold up now with financial
insurance you have a different situation
you might say look in any given year you
know three on average on average
so on an average year the fdica might
say look you know only
i don't know one out of you know one out
of a thousand banks fail so there's a
point one percent chance of failure and
of course it'll capture back some money
because it'll have some assets on
average but the reality is is that when
times go bad the bank failures tend to
be correlated because they're all
interlinked and i've done a lot you know
what they might one might be lending to
some business that's dependent on some
business that this guy is lending to the
whole financial system is all linked up
so the failures aren't aren't they they
all correlate with each other they're
not independent events so if one bank
fails it's more much more likely that
other banks are going to fail all at the
same time
and we're experiencing that right now
so you can't really call you can't
really follow the insurance model
because the statistics really don't
apply you can do this insurance model
when each of the events that you're
insuring are uncorrelated but when all
of the events that you're insuring are
likely to all happen at the same time
what you're going to have is when times
are good you're going to have a much
lower you're going to see much lower
kind of loss rate and then when times
are bad all of your guys are going to
blow up and you're essentially on the
hook for all of these people and we see
that right now and the fdic is actually
you know it's going to have to go back
to congress i'm 100 sure and ask for
more money and it's us the type we the
taxpayers that are going to be on the
line for this type of thing